[Musik]
ich habe eine vision
ich werde eine veggie burger machen und
ich glaube er wird nicht nur vegetarisch
sondern vegan und erwirbt der hammer und
ich habe gerade so viele ideen in meinem
kopf
ich musste kurz aufmalen und dann
entscheiden wir mit ja was wir machen
okay okay als er wird vegan ja das ist
ein grünes blatt also es wird ein burger
das heißt wir haben den burger bahn hier
und was dazwischen passiert weiß man
nicht aber ich weiß dass wir den teddy
aus gemüse machen hier
ich weiß auch schon wie das gemüse
resten so wie wir es wollten immer
machen unten spinat ganz viel baby
spinat uns jetzt ist die überlegung
machen wir den bürger bahn auch mit
spinat das ist ein grüner grünes
brötchen wird
coole t oder sogar rot mit roter beete
oder rote beete h oder aber es hat sich
schon mal hatte aus roter beete
praktisch so spirelli es rein gemacht so
sieht auch gut aus aber ich glaube
vielleicht machen wir es wie brote
zwiebeln und rote bete ich hier so als
spiele angebraten als sieht es gut aus
oder wir probieren beides ist noch
praktisch einmal rote beete bands und
grüne pumps und dann kann man ja so wie
unterschiedlich gelegen
du weißt dass ich mein ja das heißt bei
der rote beete nudeln würde ich den ball
grün machen und hier drüben können wir
vielleicht sogar rote beete in spa die
rein machen das es so bisher gut wird
denn mit grünem band mit rotem teppich
mit grünem so ein bisschen rotwein ja
[Musik]
wenn das rot ist da drauf dann eher
wieder was karotten es bergab mädchen
das ist natur passend haben wir zwei
rezepte gemacht auf den baum hat es
dritten roten mit dem boden brötchen die
entscheidung jetzt für eine variante
würde ich sagen
kannst du dich entscheiden
das grün die brötchen ist schon cool ok
los geht's wir packen jetzt grüneberger
man nicht noch weiter auf wir müssen
noch die soße besprechen ich glaube als
sauce machen wir einfach eine crème
fraiche im wege mit schnittlauch wir
runter tropfen mein veganer bürger nicht
nur für veganer geeignet also die
entscheidung ist gefallen es werden
spinat burger bandes und ich hoffe sie
funktionieren so auch ganz gut für den
hefeteig verwende ich einen beruf 30 und
zucker 300 gramm warmes wasser 200 gramm
veganer milchschafe oder mandelmilch zb
300 gramm frischen spinat 500 gramm mehl
2 teelöffel salz und 50 konsumboom
was sich jetzt zuerst mache ist die hefe
im wasser auflösen wenn ihr sagt ihr
möchtet den teig am tag zuvor
vorbereiten dann nehmt die hälfte der
hilfe menge das reicht dann auch aus im
prinzip müsst ihr einfach nur beachten
je weniger hefe umso länger ist die
gehzeit und je mehr hefe umso schneller
habt ihr ein ergebnis aber manche mögen
einfach keine häfen geschmack hierfür
geschmack und dann nehmen sie einfach
weniger und lasst uns länger gehen
sie ist aber auch bekömmlicher aber ich
persönlich muss sagen mich stolz nicht
dass hier einfach mit dem zucker
verrühren
und jetzt werde ich die zwei
flüssigkeiten also hefe und vegane milch
also pflanzen milch und spinat einfach
kurz pürieren
wenn jetzt keine vegane minister hat wie
man die milch oder vermint nehmt einfach
stattdessen wasser funktioniert auch
super es geht jetzt alles kurz in den
mixer das mache ich allerdings kurz ich
brauche jetzt im prinzip einfach nur die
flüssigkeit damit der spieler
verkleinert wird
ich habe jetzt hier frische
spinatblätter die oberen die hatte ich
eingefroren aber selber das problem bei
tiefe von spinat den ihr kauft ist
nämlich dass zu viel wasser drin ist das
heißt wenn ihr tk spinat benutzt einfach
die flüssigkeit ausdrücken
beziehungsweise einfach die wassermenge
dann reduzieren ihr könnt ihr dann im
prinzip einfach zusammen rechnen und
dann hast du es auch unser später
einfach nur mit der menge sozusagen
stimmen und kein flüssiger teig ergeben
so dass kurz pürieren
ganz fein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist echt irgendwie so ein vorurteile
dass jetzt diese veganern burger
brötchen einfach noch zu grün sind 100
blatt hat es nicht geschafft
na ja ich gebe jetzt hier einfach alle
zutaten in die küchenmaschine ihr könnt
den teig auch gerne verkneten
ich glaube das sieht jetzt ziemlich cool
aus
[Musik]
was hast du sie ist sehr sehr hart haben
ich hatte zuerst so wenig mehl
ich schreibe euch die die eingabe direkt
in die app und blog denn ich hatte die
flüssigkeiten zusammengezählt und spinat
dazu noch brand vergessen die menge zu
erhöhen
das war jetzt auch doch recht flüssig
und wenn sich alles verbunden hat schon
ein bisschen dann erst fed dazu geben
und auch salz denn fett und salz sollten
nie direkt zur hilfe damit sie einfach
ihre die eigenschaft nicht verliert und
jetzt einfach den hefeteig für etwa fünf
bis zehn minuten bis er schön
geschmeidig ist sieht so aus diese farbe
so sieht der teig jetzt aus und ich muss
sagen er ist schön geschmeidig klebt
aber auch ein bisschen ich mache die
später nämlich in börger ringen wenn ihr
jetzt aber sagt mensch ich will mit die
bürgerbades lieber formen so wie ich es
in meinem klassischen bürgerbahn rezept
gemacht habt dann gibt einfach noch ein
bisschen mehr mehl dazu oder weniger
flüssigkeit macht einen teig der einfach
schön geschmeidig und schön weich ist
aber eben nicht mehr klebt und dann kann
man die bürger bands auch schon formen
ich gucke jetzt mal hier aber hier hat
sich alles wunderbar verbunden ich werde
jetzt abdecken bis zur doppel bis zum
doppelten volumen aufgehen lassen
das heißt entweder eine stunde bei
raumtemperatur oder im warmen backofen
oder 30er stufe also mit wasserdampf
so trocknet die oberfläche nicht aus und
dann geht es damit gleich weiter so
sieht der teig gibt es aus vocal ich
muss sagen
gewöhnungsbedürftig aus aber ich finds
gut denn ich werde jetzt wie gesagt in
börger ringen backen
daher setze ich mir die jetzt schon mal
hierher passen so immer so sechs stück
ungefähr aus blech und wie gesagt wenn
ihr sie per hand formen wollte einfach
den teig etwas knet fehler machen sich
besprüht trotzdem meine hände mit back
transport in ich versuche zumindest als
ich nämlich immer so 100 gramm zu 80 bis
100 sind wirklich perfekt und sind sie
auch nicht so groß und ich versuche
ich glaube es gibt auch nicht so wie ich
mir das dachte nein ich wollte eine
glatte oberfläche machen aber es geht
nicht ok dann fühle ich es einfach hier
rein weil ich fand die letzten bürger
eigentlich auch gar nicht so schlecht
die haben jetzt nicht die mega glatte
oberfläche aber sie sehen selbst gemacht
aus okay das jetzt schon jetzt echt
sparen können hände waschen
[Musik]
man kriegt sogar ein bisschen runter mit
zu zweit kabel so von unten wie wäre es
mit den fingern rollen würde zeigt und
ablegen
jetzt können wir die bürger bahn
sozusagen mit bisschen back trends bei
oder öl einpinseln
patrick swayze auch vegan weil es
wirklich noch kokosfett und rapsöl ist
schon ein bisschen an die oberfläche und
stand glätten also die ganze form
ausfüllen und dann dürfen sie gerne
nochmal aufgehen so werden sie richtig
locker
[Musik]
nachdem aufgeben bestreite ich jetzt
hier die bürger noch also die teige
nochmal mit veganer milch also ich hab
ich jetzt ein haar familie geld bleibt
jetzt hier weg aber es gibt mir jetzt
auch noch mal so ein bisschen
feuchtigkeit im backofen
ihr könnt nämlich entweder jetzt die
brote mit dampf stoß noch packen wenn
ihr den dampf offen hat oder nochmal ein
schälchen mit wasser rein stellen oder
mit wasser besprühen
aber wie gesagt wenn ihr das hier so
bestreicht habt ihr auch schon wirklich
ganz viel feuchtigkeit und jetzt könnt
ihr sie bestreuen mit sesam oder auch
mit schwarzkümmel oder schwarzem sesam
ganz wie ihr möchtet
jetzt werden sie gebacken und danach
direkt mit einem tuch abgedeckt sodass
sie abkühlen dürfen
ich finde beides cool
deshalb war es vom burger das hat was
von so halloween bürger jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen mit uns hindurch
backen und jetzt gar nicht bei so hoher
hitze denn sie sollen nicht braun werden
sondern eben auch grün bleiben
[Musik]
die berge band sind jetzt gebacken und
abgekühlt und jetzt könnt ihr sie aus
dem ring herauslösen einfach mit einer
palette zum beispiel hier am rand
entlang und für uns ist ein bisschen
spät geworden das heißt bei uns geht es
morgen weiter die brötchen habe ich
jetzt sozusagen gebacken und ihr seht
auch sie sind schön luftig und locker
und dann gibt es morgen bei uns die
burger und ich freu mich schon drauf
steckte jetzt ab und lasst ihr einfach
hier rum und dann machen wir morgen früh
direkt denkt partie gehen oder das dass
das partie
[Musik]
willkommen zurück die bürgerbahn sind
wie gesagt gebacken
jetzt mache ich die pettys also den
fleischersatz und wir haben das wirklich
auch schon ganz oft gemacht die
schwierigkeit für mich lag es nur darin
alles für euch abzumessen denn
normalerweise gucken wir was wir einfach
an gemüse da haben schmeißen alles in
die pfanne sogar salat von gestern oder
vorgestern und es wird einfach alles
angebraten
ich denke aber die menge die paste zu
ich sage euch jetzt mal was ich
ausgesucht habe aber ihr könnt im
prinzip wenn ihr sagt ich mag absolut
keine karten dann nimmt halt keine
karotten oder keine zucchini nimmt
einfach gemüse was er eben so da habt
und diese partie ist die kann man auf
unterschiedlichste art und weise machen
auf bohnen basis auf soja basis auf
basis von linsen kichererbsen usw
ich habe jetzt hier nur eine variante
und wenn die euch super schmeckt dann
könnte die ausprobieren und eben machen
ansonsten firma gerne auch noch weitere
testen
ich verwende jetzt 20 kam sondern zwei
zwiebeln 2 knoblauchzehen 200 gramm
karotten zucchini habe ich 200 gramm
champignons 100 gramm linsen die sind
bereits gewaschen 100 gramm wasser ich
habe ich noch die gewürze in dem rauch
salz etwas paprikapulver edelsüß und
pfeffer und 150 gramm haferflocken
das sind jetzt zarte haferflocken aber
auch die kernigen gehen wunderbar im
prinzip müsste jetzt nicht viel beachten
sondern das gemüse einfach nur fein
schneiden
ihr könnt schneiden oder direkt
vermissen
ich mach das jetzt hier gleich im mixer
geht einfach super schnell und ich
brauch später eben auch mixa um die
masse noch mal zu zerkleinern
die karotten die sind bio daher habe ich
sie jetzt gewaschen und kann sie die
schlange verwenden schreibt nur diesen
sprung dank
knoblauchzehen brauche ich gar nicht
verkleinern
weiter zum kini auch nur hinten und
vorne wegschneiden ich habe jetzt hier
einfach gemüse ausgewählt teilweise ist
es sehr wässrig wird zum beispiel
aber wie gesagt das verkocht später
alles die champignons nach halbieren
ich hatte ja kurz überlegt rote beete
renn zugeben muss dass ich einen roten
patti hat aber ich habe mich doch dazu
entschlossen rote beete später als
spiral oder so drauf zu geben so das war
es erstmal das kommt alles hier oben
rein auf einmal oder auch zweimal
[Musik]
wenn hier das öl in einer pfanne geben
und geht schon mal den ersten stock
wenn jetzt kein mixa habe das gar nicht
schlimm dann oder gemüse einfach schön
klein dann geht das auch dass sie
tatsächlich schöne aus wenn wir uns
keinen pakt und nicht so präpariert aber
es kommt später aufs gleiche raus daher
jetzt einfach anbraten
den rest ist der kleine frauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vor sie zu ästhetischer aus jetzt frage
ich das gemüse schön an
dadurch bekommt röstaromen verliert auch
seine flüssigkeit
aber es geht jetzt hier erst mal um den
geschmack also wirklich um die reste
rungen und es dauert jetzt einfach ein
paar minuten
[Musik]
gemüse ist es schön gerüstet und ich
habe es wirklich ganz scharf angebraten
die wassermenge doch etwas erhöht denn
ich habe jetzt hier und linsen die noch
kochen müssen bzw quellen müssen
die habe ich schon gewaschen die kommen
jetzt hier rein wenn es auch schon ohne
linsen gemacht war auch super lecker
aber so hat man einfach nochmal
hülsenfrüchte mit dabei schöneweiß mit
dabei passiert das wasser rein und dann
lasse ich das jetzt hier kochen bis die
linsen gar sind mit becken natürlich da
stelle ich jetzt die hitze auch runter
und es dauert jetzt so ungefähr 15 bis
20 minuten wenn ihr merkt die linsen
sind noch nicht durch aber es fehlen
noch bisschen flüssigkeit dann gibt
einfach noch wasser dazu aber ich denke
bei uns dürfte passen denn ist oder
nicht flüssig sein sondern er dann eine
breit konsistenz haben
ich kann schon mal die creme fraiche
vorbereiten und die rote beete
vorbereiten das machen wir in der
zwischenzeit für die rote beete habe ich
hier einfach nur zwei drei zutaten ich
nehme einmal frische rote beete rote
zwiebeln etwas olivenöl salz und pfeffer
und balsamico das habe ich jetzt
vergessen herauszustellen
ich habe auch alles improvisiert und
davon nehmen wir etwa 40 glauben ihr
könnt jetzt die zwiebel und die rote
beete erstmal muss doch einen schuh
anziehen außer ihr wollt pinkfarbene
hände können das gerne machen aber ich
ziehe jetzt haben schon jetzt habe ich
pinkfarbene handschuhe und ihr könnt
dann die rote beete erstmal schälen
ich mache es aber hier im teller damit
sich mein schneidebrett nicht verfärbt
und entweder bleibt ihr sie dann so
dünnen stiften also studieren stifte
oder ihr macht wirklich spiel ist raus
und ich machte spirale und raus weil es
später super schön aussieht
ich hatte auch mal das ist richtig lange
her im halloween bürger gemacht und
hatte da auch so rote beete drauf zwar
auch von uns ziemlich schön
hier sind das jetzt übrigens auch
richtig gut aus ist dazu vor sich hin
und die linsen 10 auch schon gut aus
aber die brauchen noch ein paar minuten
aber bis dahin bin ich dann hier fertig
doch aufs schneidebrett aber ich wünsche
es dann einfach gleich weg das hier oben
habe ich hier den part nehme ich aber
benutzen morgen früh im smoothie denn
ich liebe rote beete also ich wäre so
eine spirale schneider gibt es auch als
aufsatz für die kenwood oder die
kitchenaid aber ich mache das jetzt hier
händisch
[Musik]
ich gebe dir hier schon mal in meiner
empfange ich habe eine riesen rote
bezner kinder erwischt nikolaus aber ich
glaube das reicht tatsächlich zwiebel
die schneide ich jetzt auch hier kurz
[Musik]
dann gehe ich jetzt hier direkt in die
pfanne gibt die zwiebeln auch mit dazu
kann ich das hier kurz anbraten und da
kommt jetzt das olivenöl dazu
unterbreitet ihr die masse so für etwa
ein bis zwei minuten an
[Musik]
ich würde zählung ist als und wecke ich
muss sagen ich habe etwas angst dass der
balsamico essig die schöne farbe
zerstört deswegen lasse ich das doch weg
und schaltet ihr denn heraus magst du
rote beete deswegen ich schaltete den
herd aus lass es hier so darf ruhig noch
ein bisschen bis haben
mit salz und pfeffer ist gewürzt und ich
bereite jetzt noch kurz die creme
fraiche vor
denn das hier noch ein zwei minuten
ich habe jetzt hier vegane creme fraiche
und ich muss echt sagen die sieht
furchtbar echt aus also ich habe jetzt
einfach im supermarkt gekauft marke
brauche ich nicht nennen denn ich glaube
da gibt es einfach verschiedene marken
das ist jetzt eine auf soja und mandel
basis und ich probiert jetzt auch gleich
ich finde irgendwie was das cremige ist
muss da jetzt schon rein ansonsten
könnten jetzt auch noch weiter zunehmen
oder einfach humus oder so ähnlich aber
ich finde so das passt als geschmacklich
wahrscheinlich ganz gut ich habe hier
noch etwas schnittlauch aus dem garten
creme fraiche und schnittlauch sind
nämlich auch so ziemlich beste freunde
und ich hab ja schon ich wir sind jetzt
weiter mal gespannt ob die wkb creme
fraiche mit salz und pfeffer abschmecken
hier muss jetzt die creme auch nicht so
einen starken geschmack haben denn wenn
ich normalerweise berger macht dann wird
sich das rindfleisch schlecht das heißt
habe einfach rindfleisch ohne salz und
pfeffer und guckt dann schon dass die
soße bisschen würziger ist aber hier
habe ich jetzt diesen würzigen gemüse
partie und da kommt auch gleich gut
gewürzt mit ryan von daher muss das hier
im prinzip ganz normal abgeschmeckt
werden
wow
der schmeckt so gar nicht zu ihm nach
geschmacks im nachgeschmack aber also
wenn ich da jetzt noch knoblauch
reinhauen würde was jetzt nicht tun weil
ich im blog hat könnte man es nicht
unterscheiden also echten kulisse tolles
produkt und bisschen salz so das war's
und jetzt geht es schon weiter mit dem
paradies also die linsen sind jetzt auch
raich ein bisschen flüssigkeit ist noch
drin das ist aber auch gut so ich habe
jetzt hier auch salz pfeffer und paprika
es gibt auch rauch paprika ist auch
immer ganz cool ich denke so bekommt man
einfach so diesen würzigen rauchigen
geschmack mit rein den bürger eben
normalerweise haben und hier könnt ihr
gerne auch noch kräuter mit dazugeben
gewürze mehl dazugeben was ihr möchtet
ich hoffe es jetzt mal so und schmeckt
dann auch die masse gleich ab und da die
jetzt so nicht bindet brauche ich eben
die haferflocken
die kommen jetzt hier mit rein
und damit die jetzt auch binden werden
sie noch mal püriert und dann sollte es
wirklich super mit diesem kleister auch
funktionieren mit diesem hafer kleister
wenn wir den ball kann kommt man schon
mal ganz witzig weil es passiert einfach
alles dann immer so spontan und es wird
viel improvisiert dies können auch
passend das kann und passend paprika
haben wir oft noch mit dabei das werde
ich immer so ein tolles resteessen das
könnte man oft nicht meinen und was wir
auch schon hatten hat er ja auch noch
mitgebracht hat auch schon solche vegane
pettys gemacht und dann einfach nicht
ans partie geformt wir hatten auch schon
mal aus berching geformten im eis
portionierer und dann eine forderung
einfach den raps am rhein hatte einfach
nur mal gegrillt oder ausgedrückten oder
crepes reingelegt schmeckt auch voll
lecker
[Musik]
jetzt muss noch ein bisschen
haferflocken dazu geben weil es einfach
jetzt so eine breiige konsistenz hat
aber ich will sagt gleich formen
[Musik]
die masse gebe ich jetzt hier auf einem
blech damit sie einfach schnell abkühlt
damit ich sie auch gleich formen kann
und jetzt seht die konsistenz ist jetzt
schon fest so kann ich sie nach dem
kühlen auch auf jeden fall formen also
es können dass entweder bei
raumtemperatur stehen lassen oder kurz
in den kühlschrank geben was aber nicht
so ganz energieeffizient ist deswegen
lasse ich jetzt hier einfach bei
raumtemperatur kurz abkühlen und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder die macht
ist jetzt abgekühlt und ihr seht auch
von der konsistenz ist sie relativ fest
so soll es ja auch sein
an der stelle bitte abschmecken ob noch
salz fehlt oder verfahren oder noch
kräuter die masse muss euch jetzt so
schmecken
im prinzip wäre auch schon verzeiht
bereit also ihr könnt die so auch schon
aufs brot streichen aber nein wir machen
bürger draus ich habe jetzt hier schon
eine beschichtete pfanne erwärmt denn
bei uns steht wird es gleich mit dem
burger braten los denn es ist schon
wieder relativ spät und wir wollen jetzt
einfach essen
also ich hätte meine hände mit etwa
sonnenblumenöl und ich denke von der
größe her braucht schon seit 21
portionierer voll für einen kette und
guck mal und als ich habe gesagt ich
habe das auch schon gemacht um in raps
rein
ich habe einfach so gemacht und habe so
praktisch auf dem blech und eingefahren
und dann konnte ich die so einfach
auspacken und hatte wirklich ganz ganz
schnell was für raps aber heute nochmal
pettys der sonneberger werden also
einfach in der handfläche so ein
bisschen klatsch drücken geht auch ganz
schnell
ich denke eine burger presse wird sich
ja auch anbieten aber so genau
ich denke das sollte jetzt auch gar
nicht so wirklich schrumpfen und kommt
es bei mir zumindest schon mal direkt in
die pfanne
ich werde die restlichen auch gleich
parallel zu bereiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schlagt ihr gemüse partie setzt hier
einfach bei mittlerer hitze in einer
beschichteten pfanne mit bisschen öl
einfach für etwa drei minuten von jeder
seite aus achtet einfach raus darauf
dass ihr nicht zu dunkel werden also so
wie hier in so einen hund eigentlich
schon eine schöne bräune und dann werde
ich gleich das burger bot erwärmung das
mache ich hier drüben und dann setzen
wir die bürger gleich zusammen und sind
echt schon gespannt darauf wie er
schmeckt
ok also wir machen das jetzt wo ich habe
hier gab nämlich schon den dennis sitzen
denn es ist ja sozusagen neuer veganer
also noch gar nicht so langer zeit waren
also knapp fünf jahre also kommt der
zeitraum aber hand von ende januar
das los der ball kann ich ja schon seit
drei jahren also seit drei jahren vegan
das kann sein ich werde das brot noch
kurz erwärmen
ich finde das farb zusammenspiel schock
wohl so zwischen grün rot orange was
gibt es im kreis segeberg und ich dachte
wir machen die show bisserl auch spitze
und ich meine ich mag ja auch veganes
essen aber ich mag es nicht wenn man
halt praktisch produkte ersetzt werden
die dann dich sondern auch nicht gesund
sind also so weit so ja den jetzt auch
nicht so der fan muss nicht sein es gibt
auch gutes teure produkte um himmels
willen das will ich gar nicht verteufeln
aber ich habe jetzt mal gemüse pettys
selber gemacht die bergbahnen
das erinnert mich an saure schlangen
meiner kindheit
doch die sind nicht vegan und die werden
jetzt begonnen ich habe hier übrigens
jetzt doch noch s ich drauf es war kein
balsamico aber so ein held apfelessig
ihr könnt auch einen hellen balsamico
nehmen geschmacklich hat es mir einfach
doch gefehlt und spinat den habe ich
schon gewaschen geschleudert deswegen
sie da so bisschen trocken aus und die
habe ich auch mit spinat sozusagen
verfeinert ich bin selber ich habe noch
kein bestandteil probiert also wir
gucken ist also zu einem live test ich
bin so ein proband das brot muss noch
kurz war
was ist das für eine such sitzt kein
cash vegan
da kam ich auf die idee weil ich in
deiner story die vegane creme fraiche
gesehen habe und ihr gesagt habt
schmeckt gut geschmeckt verstört und
billig ist der sessel nicht gott ok
gespannt dann das hier ja ela dass ich
gucke gleich schätze ich glaube ich mir
jetzt halt alles ein bisserl mit crème
fraiche mir das auch immer ganz gut dass
es nicht zu trocken
was war da passiert gerade so ein hier
machen so ein backflip
ich wollte hier spinat drunter machen
oder weil ich es kurz noch mal weg
setzen
es hat aber so was
das ist ein smiley der nur die augen
erst mal ich war nämlich das grün
darunter ist eine macherin burger auf
gemeindlichen ok ok als es tut mir leid
für den anderen städtischen am place
okay ich habe in meinem zeugnis stehen
sie haften mit dem management steht auch
glaube ich drin
was schreibst du mir das aber das hab
ich hab da mal was gehört
das treffen steht das bemüht brot
verbrannt ich hab mal mit meinem
austeilt ja ich merke schon der war ich
gut der war echt ich bin maßlos auf wie
bei deutschland sucht das machen wir
also das ist mein veganer burger
aber cool aus
kohl war vor allem die samira vorhin so
mama warum hast du die gefährt mit
lebensmittelfarben ich ja mit
lebensmittelfarbe hätte ich jetzt sagt
spinat hätte gesagt wenn wir bei grünen
nudeln aber sobald etwas quietschgrünen
oder kirschrot ich finde es cool und ich
komm wir probieren riecht lecker was ich
fairerweise dazusagen muss wie gut bei
so einem normalen bürger hat meyer
das fleisch ist hat das eine andere
konsistenz also die konsistenz trifft
jetzt nett aber geschmacklich finde ich
echt immer ich muss ich muss sagen also
für die konsistenz ist mit schlecht da
habe ich schon schlimmere pad ist
gegessen
veganer ich finde jetzt spuckt macht
jetzt nochmal jetzt einfach länger
auspacken können dann wäre da auch dann
wenn man bisher bis haben will kann man
ja auch die linsen noch im ganzen lassen
nicht pürieren
die haferflocken einfach eine roadmap
ist dann ist nicht alles für unsere
preise und wirklich noch ein bisschen
fester
also ich find's cool minister selbst
ausprobieren wollt testet gerne mal auch
als nicht veganer und so könnte ich
glaube ich auch schon den murat somit
überzeugen auf jeden fall
ich finde die grünen brötchen echt cool
der rest komme ein frieden und können
uns jederzeit also viel spaß beim
nachmachen
[Musik]
also so habe ich den bürger geplant und
so ist er geworden schon ziemlich cool
wie auf dem berg original wir haben
besuch ich habe gerade die tür geöffnet
weil die post kam und mit dem öffnen kam
frieda die kleine schnecke die kleine
schnitte ich habe die man eine zeitlang
gezüchtet weil in biologie in der
siebten oder achten klasse haben wir
einen film über schnecken gedrängt ja
ich war damals schon seine medien auf
jede mit meiner freundin diana und anna
mit meinen zwei freundinnen haben wir
schnecken gezüchtet und das waren meine
haustiere und dann haben wir so eine
glasscheibe genommen und haben so wie
sie sich so da hoch schlängelt und somit
ihrer schleimspur ja irgendwann finde
ich dieses material meter und dann zeige
ich euch das also hallo frieda ich
möchte dass es dir gut geht deswegen
setze ich dich jetzt noch draußen in
unser hochbeet okay da darfst du alles
essen was du möchtest